m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le coeur tout
rempli de chansons
qui referait
teulet
tous
amours d'un garçon
[Musique]
patrick je suis très heureux de te voir
et patrick toit dont hélène et les
garçons t le pote que tout le monde
aimerait avoir franchement c'est vrai on
a des problèmes on vient de voir
on n'a pas de problème on vient de voir
ses produits comme ça alors waechter
c'est vrai mais j'en ai plus le problème
aux mambas tomber ce que tu es comme ça
dans la vie
ce que tu es aussi sympathique si c est
l inverse je te peut aussi disponibles
mais je suis pas la taupe éloquent il
n'est pareil en parler c'est vrai que
c'est un amour de mecs et je te dit
patrick je connais plein de personnes
qui te connaissent et qu'ils me disent
que c'est le même dans la vie c'est un
setter latine crème là tu vois j'ai
appelé tout à l'heure du truc quand tu
manges et pour les voiliers quelqu'un
j'ai appelé patrick il a pris le train
de bruxelles et les accesoires un amour
patrick merci d'aller complètement faux
jeunes bruxelles oui mais j'entre à
paris un peu plus tôt hélène et les
garçons en plus toi tu étais l'amoureux
des reines forcément comment tu commencé
c'est d'abord tu cherches un brut a tout
de suite quand à vue pendant alors à
temps alors été très drôle parce qu'on a
d'abord fait le casting des filles parce
que ça bien sûr est ma spécialité mais
pour les garçons j'étais pas très
prétend donc j'ai observé droite à toute
une série le garçon il a fait venir les
filles et chaque fille n'a choisi son
garçon n'ont donc ces lettres ne se dit
patrick c'est dans cette logique c'est
ce qu'on veut ça te gêne bah oui on
imagine la verse aujourd'hui
ouais c'est vrai métier que tu as raison
je te jure c'est vrai t'as raison et
donc elle l a dit moi moi j'adhère pas
très bien sur la wii pas mal
ouais ouais c'est fou ça sent ouais
ouais c'est sûr sans cela ça je ne
savais pas alors quand hélène et les
garçons est quelque chose qui nous a
beaucoup amusé c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'il se passe un truc de ouf dans la
série joue un accident ou une bagarre
les acteurs faisait d entrée fracassante
j'étais un truc de la fin peut-être
compris leurs gardes savonnez un truc
important à dire
sellami elle est où un accident un
accident de moto magnitude 8 tous
premiers c'est terrible c'est johanna
harel à l'hôpital elle a eu un accident
elle se fait renverser par une voiture
elle est dans le coma il faut venir à
nicolas c'est bien utile en quoi
hélène nicolas stavy qu'est-ce qui se
passe sébastien s'est fait renverser en
moto par un camion il est à l'hôpital
mes copains vous affolez pas sébastien -
ya une équipe
[Applaudissements]
c'était tous comédiens il était comédien
patrick et et au cours florent
c'est ce que quand tu as 10 81 pas
forcément comédiens aguerris
non mais tu es obligé de commencer non
mais patrick fiori que moi je trouve
qu'il joue il jouait il faudrait plutôt
bien sans lui c'est vrai j'étais plutôt
bien joué elle aime les garçons dans le
vent mais c'est vrai en plus ce sont des
combats un épisode un épisode par jour à
une rencontre sinon aujourd'hui ça fait
rêver mais bien sûr que 10 fait est bien
ici patrick je te tue je te regarde bien
sûr le dimanche et le sait je ne demande
pas les petit air de l'amour et c'est
vrai que sans rigoler c'est moi j'ai
retrouvé tous les personnages et tout
bon et c'est un truc de fou ça cartonne
pas venir c'est pour ça que oui
malheureusement
ouais ça grandit avec qui regarde moi je
regarde pas mais aussi mais en fait ça a
bercé toute ma génération les gens qu'on
40 ans aujourd'hui on a grandi avec ab
productions viendront à tous nous
souvenir moi-même pires souvenirs de
gamin ça avec cette histoire d'hélène et
ben en fait il ya un mec qui nous
avaient dit oui on va vous emmener voir
concert d'hélène alors nous on était en
plus hélène elle était dûment comme moi
pour moi c'était la référence hélène et
on a attendu tout l'après midi leur
approchez approchez et on a pleuré
pendant trois jours parce qu'on n'avait
pas vu hélène décret du tout me souvenir
ça tourne autour de ab productions en
gros mais oui kelly basse et ça en fait
les mystères de l'amour c'est la réunion
de toutes les générations parce que moi
j'étais pas concernés par ce qu'on vient
de voir mais moi c'était les vacances de
l'amour et moi nicolas ans les vacances
de l'amour c'était c'était toute ma vie
en fait c'est tellement dur et ça a
tellement perdurer qu'on a chacun notre
notre référence printemps et les
mystères basse et là c'est la réunion
tout ça elle était fan de hockey arbh
archi fan alors ma soeur était amoureuse
même année mère ma merde
ça me rend malade aurait alors il ya ya
des bagarres aussi d'enrayer les garçons
on avait droit aussi de temps en temps
des scènes de bagarre et on voulait à
tout prix vous remonterez cette scène
culte des garçons qui vont se battre
c'est l'un des extraits préféré je crois
que patrick je sais qu'il ya dedans à
cet extrait c'est mon petit cadeau pour
toi et pour vous alors gardez
éliminables qui sont là je crois tu
cherches la bagarre aujourd'hui xe est
ce parce qu'on méritait mais attendez
mais vous êtes fous quand on essaie de
prévenir istanbul
je vous écoute moi et que deux mots en
fait nous a menti sauf à des violeurs
mais si bien que n'importe quoi j'étudie
que six coups
[Applaudissements]
c'est alors j'ai mieux pour moi j'aime
c'est les mineurs emblématique du
programme c'est bien sûr sébastien roch
cricri d'amour elle pour rappel lui
sortait avec johanna l'anglais voilà
mais visiblement un jour elle l'a
trompée avec john wayne d'heure qui fait
des films et compellent hervé et s'en
est pris à patrick pour moi c'est celle
extraits le plus drôle de l'histoire
ouais les gars que tu vas voir énorme
regarde mais ça c'est du passé on en
parle le plus c'est oublié tu vas me le
payer nicolas arrêté c'est stupide
question franchement comment faire
soigner du calme vous moquer des films
et vous êtes pire qu elle n aurait
jamais dû nous dire ça ça va je vous
excuser rien à faire nous les excuses
mais j'ose à raison vous n'allez pas
vous battre pour ça
[Applaudissements]
des patins c'est génial ça mais
franchement la droite de couper mais je
veux la voir mais la dame et remettez
l'extrait depuis le début on peut
rentrer dedans merci m'a pas touché sa
main et c'est oublier gallery pénicaud
l'arrêter c'est stupide pas touché non
non non gkd alger bien fait
est ce que tu te rappelles aussi cri cri
dont voulait parce qu'il ya un autre
jour où il a un petit peu éméché que les
cris d'amour on a retrouvé cette scène
il a une batte de baseball et regarde
c'est toi qui prends
oui on a quand même un web sso valoir la
règle de la partie devra chercher
vas-y vas-y qu'est ce que tu attends
ouais le pousse pas qu'aux turinois est
au dessus du lot